Yeah!
Ohh no
Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome to Overgrowth, the game where you play a fury little bunny rabbit and you dive, dup, dip, behh..
Dodge, duck, dip, dive and dodge your way through a series of canyons and mountains
and different pillars and cities, to try to escape the evil creatures, also bunnies and maybe wolves
that are trying to kill you with whatever they can get their hands on.
So let’s get into it. I’m going to start with the arena because that’s what I’ve been playing the most so far.
I’ve only got about maybe twenty-five minutes into this thing, but basically you’re a character and it’s all custom
built and you can fight by punching and kicking and it’s all physically based. The damage is all physical so..
Yeah I got him down. He squeaked a little bit before he died.
You want a kick to the balls?
Ow ohh!
Auww! Why did you do that?
So anyway, there’s two rounds to certain games and then you get up ‘cause you didn’t just get blunt-force trauma to
the head and auww!
Did I mention it’s kind of hard?
You can also jump really high.
No! No! I said n.. blahh
I said.. Come on. Stop twirling like a ballerina and kick him.
Don’t kick your own team.. Yeahh you like that? I kicked you when you were down. Good job teammate.
Oooh! I have a sword.
Look at me everybody I have a sword. It’s a fight to the death.
This game actually is kind of brutal. What are you doing?!
Whoa I thought you were my teammate. No! Please, I just want to live!
Aaargh! Ohh ow, okay I’m not dead, they didn’t hit me with the sword.
I’m just going to let them all fight and I’m gonna.. oh oh..
I’m gonna.. you stay away from me! You stay away from me!
You stay away from me! You stay away from me! Auw no!
Come on.
Aargh my back! You sliced me in half. Auww
You can’t escape my mad moves bro.
My sick moves. Auww what did I do?
Can I.. ohh
Yeah you’re all jealous of my mad skills over here. I’m just bleeding like pretend bleeding.
Dive attack!
Ohh come on!
If you two could stop dancing over there, that would be delightful.
Yaayy. I’m professionally skilled at everything combat.
What was I doing there?
Excuse me I’m just going to take this body back to my home. You ignore me.
Ignore me man, I just need this.
Excuse me, I.. please.. Can you leave me alone for like two seconds, I need this. I need this!
I need this for something. I need this for stuff and things.
Hello friend, you and I team up and then we do good, okay?
Ohh no?
Hey how’s it going?
I’m gonna get cha. I’m gonna get cha.
You can’t stop my crouching tiger Kong-Fu tigger bunny style.
Auw no! Auw! Why?
And I’m magically better.
Haha!
Come here. Come here.
Come on. What you gonna do?
What you up to? What you up to over there?
You want some of this? You want some of this? Huh?
What? You want some of this?
Ohh we’re going again? Oh whoops, sorry I forgot.
Don’t mind me.
What’s going on over there?
You messing with me? Walk into my circle over here.
I’m just waiting for the victor to approach me.
I’ll show you you bitch.
Come on bring it on.
Bring it on! Bring it on!
Bring it on, what you just standing there? Wow. Yeah there we go.
How did I do that?
I am Neo. I am Neo bunny.
I’m the Energizer bunny. You can’t stop me, I just keep going and going and going and aauww.. I kept going.
No!
Yeahh!
YEAH!
Are you not entertained?
Ohh another round. Oh god I was.. Oh no!
No! Aahw.
That’s what you get for celebrating way too early.
Send you across the freakin’ map bro.
Come here.
Yeah! Did you see that?
Rah-bush-ski!
[laugh]
I don't even care if I was disqualified!
Ka-pow!
Yeah!
I'm the greatest!
Whoa! Double-kill!
Hop!
Aaauw...
That did not work
Haijaaa!
Yeaa!... Ooh [laugh] nooo...
Also guys, I learned that you can do THIS.
Blaargh!
Braaugh!
Run away little bunnies!
[noises]
[laugh]
Boom, bitch!
Get outta here!
What are you doin'?!
[Markiplier's grunt]
Uuugh WHATAREYODOIN'?
Oh, disqualified
Woop
It doesn't matter Imma wolf!
bitch
Get outta here!
BOOM!
[laugh]
ARE YOU NOT ENTERTAINED?
ARE YOU NOT ENTERTAINED?!
Hey, buddy
Heey, you wanna wolf dub?
You wanna wolf dub, buddy?
Hey, buddy
What are you doin'?
What are you doin- NOTHING!
(Laugh)
Hmmmm
Well this hardly seems fair!
Owhohoho!
God!
I am MarkBot
Ready to destroy you
Eh-
Oww MarkBo-
OWWWW!
MarkBot hurt!
In..heart
BUT MARKBOT BETTER NOW!
MARKBOT TURN INTO MARKWOLF!
BITCHES!
(Laugh)
I----
AGH!!
AGHHH HE'S CHASING ME!!!
Three! Two! One!
And death
(Laugh)
And death!
Aww
Oh there's death! It was a delayed death!
There we go! There we go!
That's what I'm talking about!
That's what I'm sizzle-sayin'!
Aw no! Oh no-no! Aww hohoho!
Poor Wolfie!
He buried his face in the sand he's so embarrased
(Laugh)
Who the hell are you? WHO THE HELL ARE YOU?!
AWH I'M GONNA GET YA. I'M GONNA GET YA.
Ohh..That was..That wa- aww I..I'm..I'm..
An embarrassment to my family!
I'm gonna- oh I missed
AW COME ON!
WHAT THE- OWW! WHY? WHY CAN'T-NO!
Stop it! I'm trying to- PLEASE CAN I
Please can I- PLEASE CAN I?
Boop! Uh oh.
This is a bad idea
AND DEATH
(Laugh)
Gonna get ya! Hwoop! Aghhh yeah!
Oh it didn't kill you
I'll get ya- oh oh the old fashion way
With a FREAKING WOLF!
COME HERE BITCH!
Oww! OW!
Why are you so tou- WHY ARE YOU SO TOUGH?
You killed my wolf - not this wolf though
I'm back up, again
Oh, come on!
This guy's really good - come on
Come on, bitch
[LAUGHTER]
That actually is the most pertinent leap of logic they've - oh, come on!
They get to be behind me?
How is that a thing?
Why is this - Ah . . . No!
Not Bob!
Why is Wade the last one left?
No!
No! Wade is left?
Wade?
Wade is the only survivor - Wade died in a a wolf attack, okay
That's only fitting.